I couldn't imagine that I would be you
know I'll be doing such a lot of
interviews in front of such a lot of
cameras seven years ago but I think now
this has become a part of my life that I
have the responsibility as part of as
part of Hong Kong and also part of the
protesters and I have the responsibility
to tell the whole world how the
international community that what's
happening in Hong Kong and why Hong Kong
people are fighting so hard for
democracy and also as a as a young woman
do you feel that you're the voice of
what's happening to other women as part
of this fight for democracy because
you're worried about the police violence
yes and I'm actually after I was
arrested in the police station
during the attack the Polish hack I was
also forced to take off my trousers
of course it's very unreasonable for me
and they have no reason or they have no
you know reasonable kind of reason to -
that they have to take off my trousers -
to check my body but yeah I believe that
many of the protesters especially female
protesters are facing such a lot of kind
of attack or sexual harassment etc and
not only the violence from the police
even on the Internet as the Chinese
Communist Party were hired a lot of like
a lot of people on the internet to try
to be like like like like to like pose a
lot of comments about you know posing a
lot of comments or maybe pro-beijing
comments that you know the Chinese
Communist Party will hire such kind of
people - to make them the Internet with
some to make to increase the pro-beijing
voices on the Internet and sometimes
those people would attack like me or
all the female activists maybe by our
maybe appearance or maybe using some you
know sexual kind of description to to
attack or try to like criticize us like
once give me an example like they might
like use your like there was comments on
your appearance they would use a lot of
negative words to describe your
appearance or your body or how you dress
house your body style things like dance
and please tell me why they felt it
necessary to take your trousers off
because you're accused of something that
happened several months earlier yes and
and my you know my my my charges are not
something about you know hiding drugs or
anything like that my image Hodges is
getting involved in protest so what's
the reason of taking off my trousers in
police station for what is hacking and
but but the police didn't explain any
reason to me were you scared
well I believe that many of the
protesters who experience even more like
violence than me are most like afraid or
or experienced a a stronger fear than me
yeah it sounds pretty intimidating
though yes and and I believe that these
kinds of sexual harassment or this kind
of violence attack from the police would
continue in this movement or even in the
future Hong Kong because the Hong Kong
government keeps on avoiding their
responsibility to to have independent
investigation over the behavior and over
violence of police that's why the police
could do what they want to do so they
are not kind of being monitored by like
by a perfect kind of system so when they
are not being
properly monitored they could do what
they want to do to attack us attack
people they don't like are you nervous
about speaking to us now are you nervous
about repercussions against you after
you left this interview or anything like
that I'll say that well if we if we Hong
Kong Western so you know if we Hong Kong
listen talk to stone you know introduced
our situation to the international
community Hong Kong would become much
more terrible in the future because you
know it is always very important for
international community to monitor the
situation in in Hong Kong in the human
rights situation you know in the whole
China so that's why I would say that
these kinds of you know like for example
except two interviews from the you know
international media is a very important
thing for it is a very important thing
for Hong Kong people because you're very
self-effacing you're very reluctant to
put yours it seems to me to put yourself
in in such a high-profile positions but
you feel it's your duty oh really I'm
not really that reluctant because you
know doing these kinds of interview has
been one of the part of my life since
2012 so I kind of get use of it and I
will feel that with our connection with
the international community I have the
responsibility as part of a Hong Kongers
to correctly tell the situation in Hong
Kong to the international world but not
the Chinese Communist Party's version
mm-hmm do you see yourself as brave
I would just say that many people are
much braver than me you're very modest
how would you describe yourself as a
person your personality and what
motivates you most I would say that the
the bravery of Hong Kong people and all
a lot of young people have motivated me
to get involved or to continue to get
involved in the democratic movement in
Hong Kong it says you know we couldn't
deny that within Hong Kong as and within
protesters there are very strong sense
of desperation because even we fight we
have we have fought so hard in the
previous three months the Hong Kong
government and Chinese government to
keep on rejecting or ignoring our
opinion and our 5 demands so there's of
course a very strong sense of
desperation but if we don't stand up to
fight now we might not be able to fight
in the future anymore
so that's why you know the basic
political right to participate in
protest and the basic freedom of speech
is so important that we have to protect
it mm-hmm what do you think is gonna
happen now Agnes because every weekend
we've seen it getting worse and more and
more frantic and sometimes some some
terrible violence mostly against
physical things but people have been
injured and hurt as well
what what do you think is gonna happen
now
well we can predict that the violence
used by police it's going to be
escalated in the future stage of the
movement and but I could also say that
Hong Kong people would not easily give
up that we would continue to fight for
the five demands especially democracy a
genuine democracy of Hong Kong so if the
if the violence increases and whether
the carry lamb has already hinted about
introducing emergency that could become
very difficult couldn't it
of course solved roots political problem
in Hong Kong and to fight for democracy
it's always a very difficult thing even
if we look at the history in the world
in other parts of the world it is always
very difficult to fight for so basic
human rights and freedom but we have no
reason to give up because democracy and
human rights is something about our
dignity we as human being should enjoy
these kinds of basic rights although the
political situation might become more
kind of complicated in the future but
and the suppression from the government
will become strong and stronger also in
the future but when we faced you know
when some of our friends some of the
protests committed suicide because of
that desperation and when some of our
friends lose her eye because of the gun
shooting of the police we have to fight
harder not only just for ourselves but
also for the friends who lose their life
and who lose their eyes
do you think that any of the violence is
justified from the protesters I would
only say that in if the suppression
becomes stronger the opposition from
people would also become stronger and of
course I'm a person who who who advocate
non-violence and protest but I just I
would say that I really understand why
people would want to use different ways
to to to oppose to the government
because we have used a lot of way
already a lot of methods already to
fight for our 50-miles we have used the
most peace when the most non-violence
way protesting strike king schoolboy
court etc but the government still keeps
on ignoring our opinion so sometimes I
would say that a bit more radical action
is also necessary to in order to give
Hong Kong in order to give Hong Kong
government and the Chinese government
more pressure you're 22 I've got a
daughter who's 20 teacher loves going
out to parties who does sport whatever
what what do you do in your time off do
you have any time off or is your whole
life consumed by this well I I don't
have any I didn't have many time off
during this movement but sometimes like
before this movement or like during like
winter holiday or summer holiday I would
also have some time to you know to do
something I like and of course I i have
such you know i have hobbies and I would
do something I like like like for
example I love learning languages so
that's why I speak Japanese and I'm
learning Korea and etc so although I
start my Korean classes during this
movement because I'm too busy but maybe
after this movement or you know after we
we succeed in this movement I could you
know continue at handling Korean classes
and what do you want to do in the future
what's your ambition where do you see
you'll be in five years ten years
firstly I would like to you know I want
to continuously get involved in a
democratic movement of Hong Kong because
I know that democracy fighting for
democracy is never an easy thing maybe
we need a lot of time to fight for it
but I would once it continuously I want
to continue to join the democratic
movement in Hong Kong and well you gave
British citizenship didn't you Stanley
yes and I was disqualified by the
government because of yeah because of my
application that the government treat us
as violating the basic flow so is that
where you see your future being a
politician trying to fight that until
you you get some sort of well although I
want to be a part of election although I
want to run for the election but they
with the current situation that the Hong
Kong government keeps on abusing her
power to kick something to kick someone
they don't like out of the political
system I don't think I'm able to get
involved in any election because the
government still does have the power of
disqualifying my candidacy or
they're my friends candidacy so is it
more you fighting a point or are you
wanting to be a politician well I
of course I've ran the election last
year because I I want to do something
for Hong Kong as the legislative
councilor but I don't think I could make
this dream or target and come true
because I don't think with the current
situation the government will let me
involved in in the in any election